make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
today we are continuing our beyond omega
level series or at least doing another
episode of it and in this video we're
focusing on a character that i feel is
often overlooked when discussing the
most powerful characters in the marvel
universe especially among earth-bound
non-cosmic beings
we are covering adam bashir also known
as the blue marvel so blue marvel was
created by kevin grievous and made his
first appearance in issue number one of
adam the legend of blue marvel
miniseries
in 2008 now i'm not a huge fan of that
video because it's my old style so we
decided to remaster it but for this
video we're just gonna look briefly at
his origin before we get into his powers
so adam beshear was exceptional both
athletically and academically he
attended cornell a prestigious ivy
league school and was a football
standout while he was there now after
college he served in the korean war as a
member of the united states marine corps
and became a highly decorated soldier
now after the war he gets a job
overseeing an experiment to create a
bridge to the negative zone in the hopes
of learning how to harness antimatter as
a source of energy now the negative zone
for those of you guys who are not
familiar
is basically a parallel universe in the
main marvel universe where everything's
made of antimatter so
basically the subatomic particles that
make up matter in that place
behave in the exact opposite way as they
do in the positive matter universe like
the universe that we live in
so anyway the reactor adam's team is
using for this experiment
explodes and adam's exposed to a great
deal of radiation
and becomes a human anti-matter reactor
giving him immense powers and he becomes
a superhero
and adopts the name blue marvel so adam
beshear is loved and widely celebrated
by the american public
until it's revealed that he's an
african-american which is something the
american public finds out when his mask
tears during a battle with his arch
nemesis
conor sims now on the day that president
kennedy presents him with the
presidential medal of freedom for all
his awesome superheroing he asked blue
marvel to hang up his cape so to speak
and to retire from fighting crime
because the american public is not ready
to embrace a black superhero he agrees
to retire
but goes on one last mission to defeat
an invading alien force but the u.s
government tells the public that blue
marvel
dies in the battle and he simply slips
into a quiet life
becoming a physics professor getting
married and raising a family now blue
marvel would get back into the superhero
game at the request of tony stark who
needed his help to defeat conor sims
who's returned and single-handedly
crushed the avengers team by himself now
through a lengthy battle blue marvel
finally defeats conor sims to resume his
life as a superhero
going on to join the mighty avengers
team which was led by luke cage and then
ultimately
the ultimates which is the ultimate
avengers team which was basically a
multiversal avengers team their first
big campaign
to take on galactus and the ultimates
were amazing if you guys are curious
about that
the ultimates were done in my new style
and you'll find a link to that down in
the description so as for what blue
marvel's powers are well
he's one of several superman analogs
that marvel's created over the years
along with guys like hyperion or
century so his powers are really similar
to superman's first of all he has
superhuman strength with no
upper limit he has some insanely
impressive strength feats including
taking out the entire alien fleet that i
mentioned earlier by picking up ships
and hurling them at other ships in
another instance he was able to carry a
meteor the size of the state of arkansas
and when he throws the presidential
medal of freedom at the moon out of
anger we watch you the watcher remarks
that the impact could have been
sufficient to split the moon in too
namely the submariner also states that
blue marvel's punches rival those of the
hulk and thor
and one of blue marvel's punches was
enough to put the sentry into orbit
which is
considered to be an insanely wild feat
furthermore he's defeated king hyperion
another of the strongest beings in the
marvel universe that came from an
alternate reality and it actually killed
all the various superheroes in his own
universe and he took out the ultimate
universe hulk
with one punch it was amazing he was
just like he's like i would beg to
differ and then just
uppercuts like ultimate hulk in the face
it's like this is this this is an
amazing moment it's an amazing moment
but in addition to his strength
blue marvel's durability is so high that
he's nearly
invulnerable he can withstand strong
impacts and extreme temperatures and
pressure
without any ill effects and can even
survive in the vacuum of space with no
special equipment as he does not require
air food or water to survive to get an
idea just how insanely durable he is he
survived not only a blast from nova
and multiple punches from the sentry but
even a hydrogen bomb now blue marvel
also has heightened senses superhuman
durability and advanced reflexes and of
course
being a superhuman analog he can fly
blue marvel achieves flight by
manipulating gravity and electromagnetic
fields
and can fly at a high enough velocity to
overcome earth's gravitational pull now
blue marvel is also highly intelligent
having been shown to have intellect on
par with black panther and auto octavius
now finally blue marvel can harness and
project
massive quantities of energy and on one
occasion transferring
enough energy to carol danvers to allow
her to achieve her binary form which is
when she is at her most powerful now
typically
binary is said to have available to her
the energy of a star
and is capable of destroying planets so
we can tell just by this feat alone that
blue marvel has enough energy
that he's clearly a planetary threat in
his own right so yeah it's pretty short
video in comparison to the other ones
that we did
but that's blue marvel's powers and
feats he's a crazy powerful character
and i think one of the more interesting
superman analogs that marvel's ever
produced but i want to know what you
guys think leave a comment down below
give me your thoughts on
adam brashear on blue marvel and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you